véronic dicaire arrive dans un instant
bien jolie maman je voudrais tester vos
talents d'imitateur chantal ladesou au
revoir et coûteux alors je joue entre le
qatar et la touche pcd et chantal
ladesou
oui et c'est alors ça va petit à petit
de couilles castaldi julien lepers une
tout de suite à la 10
alors on ne sait pas
calais
[Musique]
je deviens
je me dis que tu vas faire dominique
farrugia
à évaluer fais toi plaisir j'adore cette
coupe est de buts contre guingamp
[Rires]
je savais que ça allait venir
aujourd'hui jeudi je voulais te nommer
ses mots ses mots c'est bon j'ai ruf et
la même après demain
jenifer c'est ça c'est dit
puisqu'on parle de slimane et il a tenu
à faire une surprise
[Musique]
parfois oui je pensais jamais d'oiseaux
quand vous offrez un cadeau à jenifer
c'est à dire elle est là il faut because
oiseaux mais que tu crois c'est vraiment
qu'un mec qui est justement les pigeons
il y en a qui étaient rentrés dans votre
chambre respect une heure sous la
couette à la pause et sortir ressortir
de la couette mais c'est vrai que
l'anecdote en plus oui mais on s'en fout
[Musique]
y en a qui travaillent l'après-midi et y
en a qui regarde je t'aime excitant et
lui s'arrête jamais parce qu'il s'est
emparé de mon portable pour envoyer je
te baise
[Applaudissements]
oui
il en veut dire comme même si ce que
j'ai pu lire dans la télé ce genre de
mot ça veut dire je t embrasse bien fort
ton corps et paris commence à tomber et
le land mois
j'aimerais qu'on parle de ça laurent
baffie le dico 2 confessionnal ça veut
dire quoi ban de pêcheurs ah oui c'est
un peu faim slip ses premiers témoins de
l'accident ça te parle le mieux
peut-être grillé du cul aussi il n'y a
pas que des fans aujourd'hui c'est la
journée mondiale de la télé les chéris
donc chaque chroniqueur et dans la peau
d'un animateur d'une personne de
télévision bonjour on aura des polypes
ou encore parler de moi voudrait du saut
à la perche on se retrouve dans un an
on dirait que comme tous les soirs je
suis très content pour tous et pour tous
pas bon
alors aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
tous les jeudis lancé vous l'accordé les
chéris
[Musique]
pour contourner cette épreuve
l'otan a démenti
[Musique]
c'est vraiment six grenades
[Applaudissements]
qui visait déjà réellement tombé
amoureux plus de trois fois dans sa vie
toi quand est-ce que tu meures plus de
trois fois bien bas non non une fois une
fois jusqu'à fin mai c'est quoi ses
beaux-frères cinéma qui a conduit ces
bateaux on est en bas dans tous les deux
se mélangent bosse pas dire non ça c'est
toi
fabien le cas vous êtes numéro trois
c'est votre meilleur classement j'ai vu
douze coups de minuit de ne pas de mine
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il est donc cette femme avait donné des
noms de ses chats oui on connaissait le
fameux quart d'heure son filtre de
l'émission bien sûr j'adore
alors que la promotion de son nouveau
film the two et non oui non oui non sur
concours miss france
un concours de beauté qui semble oui là
non là c'est quoi tu voi expliqué
on réfléchit alors
[Applaudissements]